[Music]
what's his arm doing
my mom get his arm what is that what is
that that little baby
tired flipper the tired that's what he
does when he's tired just like
sometimes it goes that way sometimes it
goes out are you tired bud got tired
flipper maybe you should just relax over
some postmates wow
well uh speaking of postmates if you
guys don't know we're sponsored by
postmates this episode is brought to you
by postmates postmates is amazing
amazing amazing it is a delivery service
for all your favorite restaurants that
you don't want to get off your butt and
go get yourself
post mates will do it for you download
the app on ios or android find your
favorite restaurants
and get eaten all right they'll deliver
it to you
and for a limited time postmates giving
all the dink fam 110
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days on the app to start
download the app and use code jenna
julian
check it out can't recommend it enough
amazing service also guys me undies
softest most amazing most wonderful
underwear
in the world all right
uh me undies we've been wearing them for
a lot of years and
they make wearing underwear a fun
activity
and right now you can join in that fun
activity so go to meundies.com
jenna julian okay you get 15 off your
first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee this month
through their me undies gives initiative
mandy's continues to take action to
achieve their mission of creating a more
thoughtful and accepting world by making
fifty thousand dollar donations to both
it gets better project and black lives
matter check it out thank you sponsor
this morning
so today officially not for you but for
us is the last day of birthday month
oh my god
so many birthdays all of our dogs it's
hard to make sure
that your dogs have their own special
day when there's so many of them
kermit's just listen okay his birthday
is last
so he's in the worst position to have
that celebratory
experience for his birthday pretty tired
but celebrating
but he is the most deserving of the
smallest celebration
they're fighting right now peach and
kermit they're in a brawl
you guys done kermit happy birthday bud
he doesn't deserve a good birthday yes
he does he deserves an average birthday
okay and that's what we gave him today
happy birthday bud but to be fair we've
been celebrating
they've been all having birthday months
like all months yeah they've been
getting treats they've been getting the
cake you made
we've been taking them on special long
walks cuddle sessions
i mean you name it they got it and still
kermit
continues to cry every single day so
nice sad boy
he you're 10 bud i'm so proud of you he
doesn't even know
but today is his birthday and it was
pretty lame
shh don't tell him that we hit a
week-long
kind of a week-long celebration and so
by the end of it we're just like okay
happy birthday happy birthday see
he's crying he knows it was like you
come up here because it's his birthday
oh that's why
right because he usually can't no you
gotta get peachy because now she's
jealous that no one's on the ground
i'm not carrying a dog so he wanted to
do both of those that's fine
not us right marble peach wants to sit
with bob
he's not gonna adapt you he's a dog he
might he does tired flipper it sort of
looks like dabs
no he's not gonna adapt shoes did you
bleach that shirt yeah it did
are you fighting are you fighting with
that bleach
just just a shirt oh okay i don't it's
not my preferred weapon for combat
right but why not because it's a pretty
good weapon imagine like a squirt gun
with bleach oh you know what let me add
that to the list one sec
julian what no i feel like
that's okay for like a little bit of
combat but then you'd get into trouble
what kind of trouble legal trouble no
well yeah
i don't think you can just use bleach as
a weapon
you might can what's the legality of
that like is it for self-defense
i don't know i'm scared this is not a
conversation we should be having
when in doubt don't use bleach in combat
find other methods for combat i got my
first haircut today that was not by
jenna in the last handful of months
it looks really good thank you yeah it
felt good to get a haircut what did rob
say did he make fun of the stuff that i
had done to your head
no he said you did a great job he
actually thought he was gonna lose me as
a customer
why because you were cutting my hair oh
yeah but
it's not the it's not the experience
because i'm over here being like
i don't know and i'm definitely holding
the clippers on your head for too long i
know they're getting hot
real hot we have to do it outside i
don't have one of those brushes you're
just
covered in hair yeah i missed i missed
the
experience of sitting in a i mean it's
very different he had a face shield it's
all very isolated it was
that was bizarre as everything is right
now in public but uh the experience of
having
just walking sitting down he knows
exactly what to do and i just sit there
and even you know it's like i missed
that
plus it was good to see my power out so
it was fun
what do you think i you look great i'm
not taking that
here you go no no she can go on the
floor where we put
money into a dog bed that giant-ass
like loft of a dog bed she's heavy and
she's hot
peach get in your bed what are we doing
julian
welcome to the tank i'm biased welcome
me
to the tank but
these them don't
just go i'm i'm not i'm not going to
talk over you sorry these are my
favorite
podcasts to record and make and listen
to
because i'm biased but i think that you
are
so funny and it makes me laugh so hard
me yeah
damn dude gassed me up it's so make me
laugh so hard thank you
even though most of your products are
just a good
play on words no they're not playing
words mouse plaid
that is a good product in fact you me
lady
wearing that look like you might enjoy a
mouse plaid to yourself over there and
do yourself
if you're gonna say me lady say it right
me lady
thank you you're welcome puns
are bad and i don't care cause i'm bad
too
so i use them sometimes to sell my
products
i've made millions off of puns that is
that
the end period
comma
i have more to say oh what else is
coming
thank you for having me today sharks are
gonna play the music no i don't have my
phone i don't know where it is
oh yes i do i can play my phone
you want the shark tank okay yeah you
play it no you play it no
you're you're coming in the shark tank
i'm supposed to sit here
and look cute
i just swam into the shark tank
good morning sharks sorry to wake you up
and get
i know i woke you up because we're
actually technically not on the shark
tank i'm in your hotel room
but i had a special pitch for you julian
why don't you hate when you're at a
friend's house
and they're cooking a recipe that has
pasta
but also requires some of that pasta
water in the same recipe
and your friend why would i hate that
hold on i'm not done with the scenario
and your friend an uncultured
dummy pours all the pasta water out
and then says eh it's fine we don't need
the pasta water and you think well no
you need the pasta water otherwise why
would it be in the recipe
introducing pasta water to go always
keep a clip of pasta water on you like a
bottle of water because you never know
when you're going to run into
a situation like this where you're going
to have some pasta water
and you're gonna save the day with your
pasta h2o
julian that is disgusting it only stayed
good stays good from two hours
from when we ship it so it might be bad
when you get it but it's
it's very portable it only stays good
for two hours from when you ship it
we ship it to our customers we have many
customers lots of them
really yeah no returns you know why we
don't put our return address
that's incredible it's not drinkable too
why not
because it's oh don't drink it
wait so what do people use your product
for pasta
are they cooking pasta in it they've
already cooked the pasta and then they
pour the water out
because they're uncultured so what's
your product
plus water we make our own pasta water
in-house
yeah it's gluten-free although we use
gluten as pasta to make the pasta water
but the actual water
we're pretty sure is gluten-free and
then what do people buy
your product and use it for
recipes they keep it on hand
for when they they're cooking they
accidentally pour out the pasta water
then they have pasta water to go
where are they going to the pasta
you know when people buy like food
products
you you wouldn't say like milk to go
just because that's actually a good idea
you want to go into business hold on let
me write that down
no you already smoke to go
you already have it so you can go
wherever you want with it right
so it's pasta water to go you don't have
to go
okay well it can be pasta water to stay
too but it can it's mostly possible
to go where are we going wherever the
pasta is
find it and then you save the day with
the recipe pasta water to go
what do you think what are you asking
for money give me your money how much
hold on i gotta take a call from my
business associate
he says do you want to try the pasta
water no
actually we're not interested in
investors right now oh what happened
um we've taken offense
offense yeah that you didn't want to
drink our pasta water right here now i'm
sorry
but i'll let it go if you give me a best
buy gift card to fill these 50 bucks
okay
50 okay for sure so you give me fifty
dollars yeah
best buy stock they don't have fifty
dollars fifty percent of the best buy
stock i don't have that
thank you we are part owners of best buy
you just someone
says no and you said thank you thank you
for saying no
thank you for making the deal thank you
i look forward to working with you
i don't understand your product but okay
don't cross your eyes
at me all right that was no it's over i
left
oh i don't care if you understand my
product i have your money
i have i have your money and you know
where i went
the best buy i went to go like the pasta
water
okay next one welcome
say welcome i got the guest welcome
thank you for coming you're welcome mr
wonderful
i'm not mr wonderful
oh mr horrible what is it okay that's
fine hi mr horrible
okay welcome i like the suit you're
wearing today mr horrible
thank you how's mrs horrible how's the
mrs horrible how's the baby horribles
it's like the incredibles but the
horrible
this is the family of really bad people
the baby horrible
horribles introducing my new service
that i've invented today
google mail we use google's information
network to send you mail
we call it gmail for sure no wait what
it's called gmail for short we call
around the office we just say gmail
because we don't feel like saying google
mail
yeah but we uh we basically send spam
mail
to your physical mailbox using google's
information network
and we don't tell google about it
do you have any idea hold look at me do
you have any idea how many how many
addresses google has i can't look at you
thousands of addresses that's horrible
public domain babe
everyone's in like mailbox would be
stuffed oh that was [ __ ]
when the mailbox this is what we say
around the office when the mailbox is
stuffed
our pockets are two okay you know
gmail do you want to invest in gmail
sounds like a winner you can't use the
name gmail you're not a lawyer
you're not tell me i'm wrong are you
secretly a lawyer
didn't think so
when someone tells you you can't do
something you're not alone
here's the way lawyers work if you can't
see them they can't see you
it's like shutting your eyes when you're
a kid if they can't see you
you know you can't see them they can't
see you just
invest in gmail i don't want to i don't
want it how about this
what you invest in gmail i'll do
whatever you want for a week
whoa like what
i don't know sexual favors oh my god
i don't even know you no no we know each
other well no we don't
okay um non-sexual favors just platonic
favors
like what running to the store okay grab
you some snacks
but i don't like your company i'm gonna
invest
51 percent is what i want of your
company so that i can disband it
50.1 sure i'll have 50.9
no that's not how that works no it's 101
business
no yeah we got an extra percent no all
right so you won 50.1 percent i'll get
49.9
yes all right deal all right i've shut
down gmail
what it's over that's not what i want to
do i don't want [ __ ] in my mailbox
you can't shut it down majority
shareholder tough [ __ ]
i'm not gonna do any favors for you i
don't care you're not a lawyer
damn it checkmate
me okay
can you play this on nope okay
welcome for one second don't you have
those friends of yours who are just
first of all they're just really [ __ ]
annoying
yeah sure and most of them are like
iphone or android carrying citizens
who have the ability to look down and
see what time it is
but they somehow always find the need to
ask you hey what time is it
yeah first of all reconsider your
friendship choices second of all
introducing neck watch it's for the
people you are with who need to know the
time but you don't need to know it
it's like a dog collar but with a clock
on it completely impossible to see if
you're wearing it
check watch
do you know those really thin disc
batteries yeah it requires 45 of them to
power
wait so is it like a choker yeah it's
like a choker it's very small
is it comfortable um do you like being
choked
sorry uh no it's not comfortable
it's very uncomfortable also there's a
tracking device in it
so we know where all of our customers
are
don't mind that because we're not
lawyers who cares
nick watch
[Laughter]
the way you said do you like being
choked and then immediately looked
forward and down sorry
i am sorry for that if you'll excuse
that we could potentially have a really
are the batteries not fluffy fluffy
business relationship flourishing
business relationship with nick watch
what are the batteries are not included
we are not sourcing those better they
are so annoying to find they don't sell
them anywhere
and you need 45 of them you go to like
cvs and there's like
you know you need a circular flat one
yes and then there's like
70 there of all differing sizes and
you're like you got to try them out i
don't know i
[ __ ] up i don't know what kind it is
but it's worth a headache because then
your friends won't need to ask what time
it is
for like a couple of months can't you
just get your friend like
a watch yeah but that would require you
buying something for someone else and
who likes doing that
you like buy certified stuff for you me
so what do you say i'm asking for five
hundred thousand dollars for 40
40 halfs of a percent and
you better fix that offer 500 thousand
dollars for
14.5 percent of my company i actually i
don't hate the idea
of a necklace like a choker that is a
clock
i think that's super fun neck watch
and i don't mind neck watch i think
that's a fun name
i think it's cool and could be trendy
but i wouldn't market it as
to help your friends remember the time
well we can have some discussions that
we can go back to the drawing board
fashion do you know fashion wait are you
fubu
damon damon do you know fubu
deal put me on the fubu line we gotta do
i wish yes
fubu neck watch
if it was a fubu neck watch i would buy
it off brand like no name brand
neck watch i don't know but if it's fubu
it's like the drake meme no name brand
no no no fubu yeah exactly that's
that's everyone talking about fubu all
the time birthday boy
okay ready yeah
hey sharks every time i use a french
press i think to myself
why do i have to press this thing down
so slow
i'm already tired it's the morning it's
like a five minute process of putting
the
the plunger all the way to the ground
four seconds and i basically want to
fall asleep in that five minutes
just so slow every time i do it i think
of this
i'm already trying to get energized
which is why i'm drinking coffee in the
first place
but yet because of this outdated
technology i'm moving like a turtle
introducing french slam
it's the world's first french press that
only works when you full force slam it
down
it multiplies the caffeine content by 30
percent
and i guarantee you'll like it
i told you already i already told you
i'm not going back in my pitch
what percent i already told you
0.5 do you agree that french slam could
be a big hit
in the fitness industry people want to
slam their coffee down
why not make them slam it to create the
coffee french slam
i don't we could sponsor the grand slam
it's a tennis tournament isn't it that's
not a bad idea
french slam bring brings you this year
the grand slam
and then everyone in the crowd goes to
the concession tables and slams himself
some french slam
wait so if you have a french press yeah
couldn't you just slam it down
no because it would go everywhere our
patented technology makes it completely
safe and clean
do you have a roommate yes oh
oh no you tell them to move out
they might not like it it might make a
mess
you're my roommate oh i like it i'll
stay
okay what i thought you said it was
clean how's it gonna make a mess
usually when i tell people it's clean
i've already had i've already sold it
it's really interesting so our
technology is almost there
okay um we have a couple scientists that
we've hired on fiverr that are still
waiting to get back to us on how we can
make the force
dissipate at the very bottom but still
slam it down with all of our might
it's uh it's almost there okay
i'm interested yeah yeah how much money
did you need
france is actually already investing in
the country really
yeah because it's called french slam and
they want they want to
they want a piece of it you know where i
think your
target like market would be
at denny's with a grand slam breakfast
do you know a guy denny's do i know a
guy
yeah do you know someone who works there
sure okay
if you will get us into denny's i will
let you in on the ground floor for no
less than one million dollars right now
just take my hand
imagine though getting a grand slam
breakfast while you slim your french
slim
with your coffee well everyone's
favorite part about the french press is
getting to do it themselves but everyone
who does it is like oh this is so boring
imagine they bring the french
slams slam it down your day is only
going to get better from there
well also think of it like a
in a coffee shop you know like when
you're out with your pals
and everyone decides to do sake bombs or
you know like uh some type of shot that
is lit on fire
yeah it's like that but in the morning
in the morning
and you french slim and it's it's like a
sake bomb for breakfast
exactly can i use that tagline um you
know i don't think so
sake bomb for breakfast i'm gonna
message my
i don't have anyone okay deal deal we're
in
we're in yes nice yes
speaking of denny's breakfast is always
really good julian so you can order it
on postmates any time of the day
breaking for dinner why not postmates be
like sure i'll
bring you some breakfast for dinner it's
okay bud we've actually been eating a
lot of breakfast for dinner if you want
some potatoes
uh some fries some uh brekkie sandwich a
salad i don't know what you want but
postmates
will deliver it for you right to your
face
and they have contact free delivery
if you opt in for that within the app
you can select to do that is
actually really nice i've been doing it
when we order post mates you just tell
your postman hey
i'd like for you to leave the food here
and i'll come out and get it and they're
very always very accommodating
postmates makes ordering food
just the easiest thing ever and
sometimes i'll be browsing postmates and
i'll be blown away at how they're
constantly adding new options
for my gullet to eat how do you have to
call it golet
because that's what it is all right
you can order local food and support
local small businesses with postmates
they have a lot of
amazing restaurants and a lot of amazing
places so check it out
right now okay for a limited time
postmates giving you guys a hundred and
ten dollars of free delivery credit for
your first seven days on the app
so download post mates in the app store
and use code jenna julian all right
check it out you will not be
disappointed also guys me
undies an amazing product backed by
amazing people
who as i said earlier are going to be
donating 50
000 both to the it gets better project
and black lives matter they are
committed to standing up against hate
and intolerance and creating a world
where hope outshines fear for all people
with me undies gives simply by shopping
meundies you help them
support this cause me and these as you
know are three times softer than cotton
made of micro modal fabric
they have onesies they have bralettes
they have
socks they have all sorts of different
soft things for you to put on your body
and enjoy it they jenna dubbed the
onesies gamer onesies because she is a
gamer and wears the onesies
i personally think they should they
should rename them to that because it's
perfect
it's the game in onesie they offer a
range of sizes all the way from extra
small to 4xl
and right now you can get 15 percent off
and free shipping
when you go to meundies.com or click the
link
down below in the description check it
out
they have new uh designs all the time
and uh
you will love them thanks mandy's thank
you sponsors
all right moving on
what why'd you just take such a deep
breath
you ever you ever see those electric
pepper grinders
yeah they suck because you have to
change the batteries in them and you
have to charge the batteries who wants
to do that
how about what if i told you if i made a
solar powered
pepper grinder julian you need to store
it outside in the backyard
so it might be a little dirty but
there's a little solar panel on top of
it
and it translates to five whole minutes
of automated pepper grinding
so you leave it out for a couple weeks
bring it inside and you're putting it
over your pasta you just hold it
it's very heavy and it grinds itself it
grinds pepper
without you having to do this like five
or six times once
instead you hold out the really heavy
object for about two minutes
and it should grind enough pepper
to your liking also it's voice activated
so if you say more
it will continue thank you for coming
so so we're in business thank you for
coming
when will we when will i see the
documents you can
expect something from gmail from me
oh the one in your mailbox oh the
physical gmail
yeah i don't like those guys did you
invest in them watch your uh watch your
mailbox for some gmail
i don't you'll get a letter from me
you'll we'll be in touch
okay thank you
so that's that's a no
hi sharks how do you do
i do me too how do you like cooking
all right i personally hate it every bit
of it i hate
from the beginning to the end it's
misery
but i've invented something that makes
it a lot more fun i
hate chopping things this isn't me
personally julian i love chopping things
i love cooking but this is a
i'm playing a character oh i'm character
acting
okay okay what's your name resume
penny i have invented the best new
device for everyone who sucks and hates
cooking
sucks at and hates cooking okay okay it
is called
the sharpest cutting board in the world
julian
it is the knife no knife required
cutting board
every time you're ready to cut some
onions and some bell peppers you have to
get your
knife and your cutting board and you
have to chop it up
like you're some sort of lumberjack in
the kitchen it doesn't make any sense
i'm not trying to cut anything
well with it the world's sharpest
cutting board all you do is drop it onto
the cutting board and
15 upward facing knives glued to the
cutting board will do all the work for
you
no no work necessary also it's really
hard to clean so you just don't clean it
ew no don't don't get bacteria no you
can throw it in the dishwasher
if you want to break your dishwasher oh
[ __ ]
but there's 15 really sharp upper 15.
25 really sharp upward facing knives
just pointing up
all you do is drop an onion you it lands
and it goes and it completely dices it
up
amazing how do you get once you just
stay with me
once you drop the onion on top of it how
do you get the onion
out well it comes with a pair of
chopsticks so you detach the chopsticks
from the side and you just fish out each
of the pieces
uh that are all perfectly sized up i
guess it would make more sense to have
like a little well underneath it and it
would just catch everything
what do you think about developing that
we're really low on money
hold on i have to read the rest of my
pitch i have to read the rest
we've been featured on youtube
does that mean you have a youtube video
yes okay as seen on youtube
okay we're in the as seen on youtube
section you know that youtube is a
democratized platform like anyone can
upload on there so being featured on
their
meaning very good yes uploaded okay
i'm a little concerned about the safety
of your product it seems
kind of dangerous why um because it's 25
knives pointing straight out but you're
not touching the knives why would you
need to touch them
to get the pieces out what if we
developed a little
detachable well at the bottom then would
you invest
i would think about it it's not
dishwasher safe don't even think about
it
it's really inconvenient
but it's safe how am i supposed to how
about this well it's all safe
just not this one we'll install a little
plastic guard
above the knives okay oh wait no that
would block the fruit
okay that would render the product
completely useless okay
um do you want to invest i don't think
it'll work
i think you still have like some design
issues to
to figure out i don't like the product
it sounds like a prototype
every day i go into work i really hate
it
someone comes to the shark tank they're
like yeah you're right i don't i don't
like this and
i don't like this do you guys need like
a pa or something are you hiring
i need to get out of this gig i'm not
gonna invest
okay a good call but thank you hit me up
later we'll hang out okay
penny
oh hi sharks do you have friends
yeah how many of them live near you i
don't know a few
how many of them live not near you a few
do you have enemies
answer um sure how many of them live
near you
they're in video games how many of them
live not near you
still in video games everybody's heard
of pen pals
keeping a friendship good spicy from a
distance using paper and pen
but what about those who have wronged
you
and are far away how did they get so far
away
how did you let them are you just going
to let them get away
no way pick up that angry pen
and start writing with pen enemies
we are a service that connects two
enemies from very far distances
and transports letters between them
you can you can fight
as long as you want using our service we
will guarantee
that your enemy sees what you wrote
how do you guarantee that they see it
we guarantee it okay it's guaranteed we
guarantee it
we have a large information network
and we know where everyone lives so all
you need to do
google we're not google
we're googles how did you know we're
google
i'm not wearing my google shirt
i know it's okay
um just just download our app
okay just download our app it's only on
kindle
and oh come on but you can't write on
kindle you just download the app and you
say
um i hate this guy named kyle okay
and then they they're like okay write a
letter
and you write a letter and you send it
to us and we take it
and we put it in another envelope and we
send it to kyle and then kyle gets it
and says this was [ __ ] rude i want to
say something and then
kyle says okay i want to send this to my
pen enemy and then we just we're making
connections all over the world possible
it's really beautiful
i love my work i honestly i'm sure that
people would use that service
even if it's a joke it sounds fun and
funny and i don't really fully
understand how it's any different than
mailing someone a letter
like what you're saying providing we're
the middleman we have information so
why do you need a middleman to send a
letter
because when you're an enemy with
someone
oftentimes they'll keep their
information private okay so you're
violating them by
sending them a letter correct yeah okay
but what do you care
they're your enemies who cares if we
violate their privacy you don't care oh
my god
durian that's well coming from google
yeah
i guess you know
what was that nothing i gotta go
oh what happened i gotta go my boss is
paging me
you have a pager yeah mr google
what cell phone service do you have that
still allows you to have a paper towel
wow so we are we got a business
pen enemies let's do it invested done
thank you for investing in pen enemies
that's me every time i have to vacuum i
hate it
who likes to walk around their house
with a giant robot that's sucking up a
bunch of dirt
it's boring you have to plug it in a
bunch and if you don't have to plug it
in you have to charge it
the dogs usually don't like it wouldn't
you rather just walk around your house
and have it magically clean itself
well now you can with suck feet
the world's first miniature vacuums that
get completely
enclosed in the design of a normal shoe
they're equipped to suck up dirt and
dust and your foot
can cover an entire however big your
foot size space
per step and suck up all the dirt with
foot sock
that was called suck feet suck feet
did i say footstock is it foot suck
suck feet s-u-c-f-e-t wait
s-s-u-c f-33t
suck feet it's our same username on ao
[ __ ] gamertag we're the same on xbox
live and aim
suck feet oh my god um so it's great all
you have to do is take a walk around
your house and then it'll be clean it's
completely silent too and you don't have
to plug them in there's no batteries
required
it's really not the worst thing i've
ever heard the idea of
of cleaning while you're walking thank
you but i feel like people have done
that with like
swiffer type things on your boots or
your feet or
something socks so it's like that but
better
that's pretty cool not waterproof though
okay but julia don't step anywhere near
water you'll electrocute your entire
body
what okay that's that sounds like a
safety hazard
um so in a vacuum usually there's like a
compartment or a bag
where the dirt and dust is going right
yeah yeah where
is where is it going um it ejects the
dirt behind you
so don't walk behind someone using sock
feet
basically just spreads the dirt
elsewhere but it looks really clean in
front of you when you're
using it
so does it actually clean yeah one could
say that it does
one could also say that it doesn't but
that one wouldn't be welcome in this
room
suck feet
we might need some work but i'll invest
in sexy i'm getting so much money today
okay
how many times have you been at a meal
in public or at a friend's house where
they're eating something that you just
wanted a taste of
maybe you don't want a whole meal yeah
you just want to taste yeah
and then they grossly offer you a bite
with their spoon and you say no that's
gross because it's gross why would you
eat from their spoon
disgusting you slap your friend you have
a fight about it
not physically slapped no i mean that's
rude you would
you would verbally slap them a little
bit a verbal slap
okay where are we going
but you can still have a bite of their
food because you reach for your wallet
and
oh what's perfectly folded up in there
wallet spoon
it turns into a credit star credit card
size square
rectangle uh but when you unfold it it
turns into a spoon
even though it's completely flat and you
just pop it out take a bite
of their sloppy joe and then you wipe it
off on your shirt and you put it back in
your wallet
don't they make products like that like
little
travel sized spoons and forks not
disposable though you reuse this
and it can't get wet why it will rust
instantly it will rust very fast
isn't it getting wet by like going in
your mouth
sharks that is what she says
i'm not investing i don't like you as a
person
that's fair that's fair i get it
okay moving on
roller coaster insurance julian that is
all
wait what that's it i'm gonna walk
around theme parks and offer people
insurance for the roller coasters that
they're about to ride on
for the roller coaster for the person
well i'm protecting the people
okay i take their money up front
and i say if anything happens on this
roller coaster right
i will be there to help you they get on
the roller coaster and you [ __ ] get
out of town you are so far away no i'm
julian
it is a scam
you just watch them go on the
loop-de-loop and they might as well be
on a different planet dude because
you're out of there
no why not because that's criminal you
can't just take money from people and
offer them a service that doesn't exist
i think that i can no
you're not a lawyer you're not a lawyer
either
okay so no no
how many times have you been on a date
not very many it was rhetorical and
and while you're on a date there is a
person
at the same restaurant or location that
is just
really like good looking
or doing something desirable or just
overall
you know they're a catch and then you
look back at your date you're like damn
i wish i could be with that well we have
a service that basically does the
opposite
introducing date dummy we are a paid
actor service for people to crash your
date location and do something really
bad so you can look good by comparison
oh my god
current supported actions include
yelling at service workers
talking loudly in small spaces public
intoxication and pooping on the ground
like a dog
in no time your date will be thinking
well at least they're not that guy
sounds like a like a prank television
show there's no cameras
yep you say yet no
didn't i didn't say it did you know that
the word
didn't is spelled d-i-d-n
t i didn't know that
i didn't d-i-n-t
yes i did i did it feels good to say
like that
i didn't i didn't and kai
can i is spelled k-a-i okay
so yes or no on this it's a bad idea
isn't it i'll i'll come back
uh we're bullied beta testing oh like
it's the worst but i'm just
not 100 sure how your actors can
poop on the ground like a dog and not
face consequences
yeah you can't just be like oh he's one
of our actors sorry he pooped in your
restaurant
well we can and we have julian
i understand i get your hesitation okay
okay rice cubes they're like ice cubes
built with rice
never mind i just wrote that down that's
just a word
how many times are you at a public
location and you look up into the corner
and you see a security camera
and your first thought is
damn i wish i could see through that
camera because i look good today
well now you can introducing security
polaroids
all you need to do every time you see a
security camera is hold up a qr code on
your phone
and the camera will morph into a
polaroid and drop you down
a beautiful picture that you can use on
your instagram or instagram stories
not supported by facebook right now
you have the technology to to morph a
security camera into a polaroid camera
well it's funny
one of our engineers um
he doesn't speak english but what we
think he's saying is that every security
camera
in the world already has the hardware
necessary to print
a polaroid photo from it we just need to
hack in with our qr code
and provide them so you're hacking well
did i say hack
i meant integrate
we're integrating with other people's
inventions
and intellectual property yeah again he
doesn't speak english
i wish i understood what he was saying
are you the same person that sells
roller coaster insurance why are you
looking for a roller coaster
[Music]
no no no
i just sprinted out
[Music]
imagine someone gets denied on shark
tank and just full sprints out
no how about full sprints in i would do
that
i would do that too that's how i would
do shark tank that's how you do shark
tank
i agree i just run right between their
chairs
you go hi sharks you throw your product
at them and then you sprint up
yeah well i have a couple more but i
think most of the ones that i have on
paper here will be developed in the
coming months and years and
for the next episode of shark tank on
the podcast i will have those nice and
ready
this is my favorite it really is that
sound good it makes me laugh i'm selfish
i like to laugh
and this makes me laugh well good i like
making you laugh i hope you enjoyed my
pitches and i hope to be hearing from
you professionally soon
sock feet
come here from you
i really liked your products oh she
i really liked your products um i think
suck feet's a good idea we just we need
to figure out a way to not
throw the dirt all over the room yeah
that's a little bit of a design flaw i
think but we'll get there
yeah or we won't that's fine i have a
lot of inventions and ideas
cool well thank you for joining me
you're welcome
thank you guys for listening to our
podcast we'll be back next week with
another podcast
it's grammy's birthday birthday
are you excited but for all you papas
out there happy father's day i believe
it's father's day tomorrow
or yesterday for you anyway thank you
guys so much
um fun times and uh
we'll see you on the next episode of the
jen and jillian podcast thank you for
listening we love you guys
[Music]
you